just utilize our sound recently
imagine
oh you and I we know that God is perfect
for the time
it's a reality god is perfect there's no
beginning to end and it's
self-sufficient
it's not in need of nothing
and everything's in need of him correct
yeah yes
so we Jesus
was getting breastfed by his mother
these are the same God who is
self-sufficient
he's a Son of God oh Jesus the baby the
child human baby according to the Bible
the world became flesh and the word is
God so God they can flesh to the flesh
that was holding that was God who became
a flesh
baby it was it was The God Who was
self-sufficient who was not in need of
nothing all the time by who is in need
of milk to survive isn't that amazing
isn't it amazing what a miracle
that God
Miracles
that's nonsense there's no Miracles
you've asked me a question can I answer
can I answer it you know what I said
you're saying it's ridiculous that God
who is powerful oh sufficient the god
that does not need anyone now needs to
soften his mom's titties
yes I've said back to you what you said
to me now I'm saying that's amazing a
miracle because how amazing it is that
the god the creator of the universe so
it fits to come into flesh the
incarnations are the most the most
unbelieved act ever done that the god of
the universe would take the ship of a
man
also remember the mother was told she
was the married adult vision when she
was so that the holy spirit will come
upon you
know you just repeat yourself
once more by saying you just said to me
God is not in need of nothing
so if God is not in need of nothing all
the time but therefore it's not a need
of anything so if you say to me God is
Not only does nothing then God is need
of something that's contradiction for
that's reputation
he's got a need for anything
no he's not doing anything so God is not
in need of nothing all the time
so when Jesus was a baby was he in need
of the milk to survive
survive
I don't know he wouldn't that's why she
was giving him milk I don't know
Casey
[Laughter]
that was God
Jesus God chose to Humble himself so
much of a woman so God that humble
himself for someone
take care of yourself
I can't help you nah you can't you can't
argue someone like that yeah of course
himself
God does not need to become a cockroach
and the father never become a baby it
was a son so what the father himself you
see alhamdulillah
people please imagine Christian out
there he just said God humble yourself
becoming a baby for someone to chase his
nappy imagine this imagine nonsensical
belief the almighty so if if someone
comes to you listen I believe in God
they can cockroach he said no he said
yeah humble himself
but it's perfect that's where I come to
Islam that's why Christianity is dying
and I believe it's Christian future are
doing a great job for us
that's why I use them to show with their
own tongues where the Christians really
believe for the Christians out there who
have sound reasoning to know Christiana
doesn't make missions
foreign
must self-sufficient is not in need of
nothing that all the time you just told
me he goes under nothing then tell me
because he was in need of the milk
contradiction
if you get nuts neither will he begotten
and there is nothing
look the description of the almighty the
greatest
long time
where have you been
the creator of his creation is Allah the
Bible and the Christians believe and you
see how they describe Allah you know for
a fact his creation was not created by
the god of the Christians because our
baby someone says universe doesn't make
any sense
as you know we are we have a campaign to
raise the money for our Masjid or to buy
a new place because as you know the
current place that we have behind the
market subhanallah is I believe you did
see or if you haven't seen it yet go
back to our Channel
and see it the place is very terrible
but like it's very hard to watch true
it's more safe for women or children to
come so we are raising money we haven't
found a place yet but what happened we
are raising money because what happened
in the past if you don't find if you do
find a place we don't have enough money
for deposits so we raise and manage
Allah while we are still looking for a
new place so make sure you have us may
Allah bless you